[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Gundula
Gause und Anne Gellinek
[Musik]
guten Abend heute hat unser Militär in
Issum die ersten Leihgaben aus Russland
entgegengenommen spottet ein Berater des
ukrainischen Innenministers über die
erbeuteten russischen Panzer nach der
blitzoffensive und ein ukrainischer
Kriegsreporter setzt noch eins drauf
vielleicht brauchen wir jetzt gar keine
Leopard Panzer mehr ungeachtet der
euphorischen Zitate ist der Druck auf
Deutschland weiter gestiegen gerade
jetzt wo die russische Armee plötzlich
besiegbar scheint müsse Berlin endlich
Kampfpanzer liefern findet nicht nur die
Opposition mattes Feldhoff berichtet
es sind Bilder des Triumphes auch wenn
es nur kleine Gelände Gewinne sein
sollten die Ukraine feiern jedes
befreite Dorf jede befreite Stadt als
Sieg über Russland wie hier in isuma
südlich von Kraft
alles drumherum ist zerstört wir werden
alles wieder aufbauen die suma war ist
und wird Ukraine sein
Ukraine es sind die Waffen die den
Unterschied machen Waffen wie die
Panzerhaubitze 2000 die auch Deutschland
in den letzten Monaten geliefert hat
erst zögerlich dann aber doch doch der
Druck steigt noch weigert sich die
Bundesregierung Schützenpanzer wie den
Marder oder den Kampfpanzer Leopard 2 zu
liefern und so bleibt es bei den
bekannten Kanzler Mantra gegen weitere
schwere Waffen
ansonsten bleibt es bei der Haltung die
die deutsche Regierung seit Anfang an
eingenommen hat und die auch für die
Zukunft unserer Haltung sein wird
nämlich dass es keine deutschen
Alleingänge gibt noch kein Land hat
schützen oder Kampfpanzer westlicher
Bauart geliefert und wir haben uns
darauf verständigt auch mit unseren
Partnern dass wir da keine deutschen
Alleingänge machen der Bundes gern
verweist der sozialdemokratische Teil
der Regierung auf das was man gemacht
hat fast 60 Positionen mit militärischem
Material umfasst die deutsche Liste
Material für über 720 Millionen Euro
eine Liste die man gern herum zeigt
darauf unter anderem zehn
Panzerhaubitzen 2000 54 Transportpanzer
M113 geliefert von Dänemark bezahlt von
Deutschland 15 flugabwehrpanzer Gepard
oder
500 Stinger Raketenwerfer
wäre die Lieferung von Marder oder
Leopard Panzern der deutsche Sündenfall
oder ist in Wahrheit die Position von
Kanzler und Verteidigungsministerin der
Alleingang in der Ampel sind die
kleineren Koalitionspartner längst
anderer Meinung es ist klar dass wir
mehr liefern müssen auch schweres Gerät
und dass wir uns dabei alles anschauen
müssen auch die Bestände der Bundeswehr
die Bestände der Industrie die Ukraine
ist erfolgreich in ihrem Kampf gegen die
Aggression Russlands und deswegen wären
wäre es jetzt sehr gut wenn wir neben
dem Dingen die wir schon geliefert haben
Panzerhaubitze Gebhardt jetzt auch
Panzer liefern könnten und zwar sofort
Ukraine kämpft unseren Kampf für Frieden
und Freiheit und Demokratie und deswegen
müssen wir sehr schnell jetzt
nachliefern tatsächlich war die
spd-argumentation im Frühjahr noch nur
nicht Putins Russland provozieren doch
Moskau hat sein Urteil längst gefällt
der russische Botschafter sagt heute in
einem Interview allein die Lieferung
tödlicher Waffen ist eine rote Linie die
die deutsche Regierung nicht hätte
überschr dürfen
im Osten der Ukraine wie hier auf dem
Soldatenfriedhof in diepro begraben sie
immer noch täglich ihre Toten ohne die
Lieferung westlicher Waffen darüber gibt
es wenig Zweifel während es
wahrscheinlich noch viel mehr
unterdessen geht der Krieg trotz oder
gerade wegen der Geländegewinne der
Ukraine weiter die russische Armee nahm
auch letzte Nacht die Großstadt harkev
unter Beschuss und griff offenbar
gezielt die Strom- und Wasserversorgung
an Präsident silensky wertete die
Attacke als Vergeltung für den
ukrainischen Vormarsch unsere Reporterin
Katrin Eigendorf ist in rakif
die Feuerwehr in hakif heute im
Dauereinsatz ein Verwaltungsgebäude im
Zentrum steht nach einem Angriff in
Flammen in vier weiteren Stadtteilen
schlagen am Mittag die Geschosse ein
erst langsam trauen sich die Menschen
wieder auf die Straße viele haben in
ihren Kellern Schutz gesucht
ich fühle Schmerz und Angst verstehen
sie wer konnte sich vorstellen dass so
etwas bei uns passiert ich verfluche die
die das gemacht haben
in einem Wohnhaus nicht weit entfernt
irren die Bewohner durch die Trümmer
verstört fassungslos mitten in der Nacht
wurde das Gebäude gleich mehrfach
getroffen jetzt untersucht ein
Ermittlungsteam der Polizei was genau
geschah
in einer Wohnung im Erdgeschoss treffe
ich Pavel wie durch ein Wunder hat er
überlebt denn die Geschosse schlugen nur
unten ins Wohnzimmer ein
ich schlief in der zweiten Etage es gab
zwei Einschläge sie wollten
wahrscheinlich das Haus treffen das ist
das Ergebnis das ist ziemlich traurig
kaum etwas ist heil geblieben leben
können Pavel und seine Frau hier nicht
mehr was jetzt wird er weiß es nicht
wir stehen alle noch unter Schock wir
haben fast alle nicht geschlafen in der
Nacht es ist schwer
Stück für Stück sammeln die Polizisten
die Splitter der Geschosse auf alles
wird genau dokumentiert Beweise
gesammelt denn jeden einzelnen Angriff
will die Ukraine als Kriegsverbrechen
zur Anklage bringen
eine Frau wurde so schwer verwundet dass
sie am Morgen noch im Krankenhaus starb
die anderen Bewohner sind mit einem
Schock und leichten Verletzungen
davongekommen
wir sind in den Flur gelaufen und haben
geschrien um zu sehen wer ist noch am
Leben es war wirklich furchtbar wir
haben alle geweint
doch sind nicht nur die Angriffe auf
ihre Wohnhäuser die die Menschen in
hakif in Angst versetzen immer wieder
Zielen die Raketen auf wichtige
Infrastruktur in der Nacht wurde das
Elektrizitätswerk getroffen stundenlang
fiel der Strom in der Stadt aus der
Bürgermeister und auch der Gouverneur
warnen vor weiteren russischen Angriffen
auch in dieser Nacht
und uns zugeschaltet ist jetzt unsere
moskaukorrespondentin für Bega für die
Ukraine machen sich lustig über die
wegrennenden russischen Soldaten wie
wird denn der Rückzug der russischen
Armee in Moskau verkauft bekommen die
russischen Bürger überhaupt was davon
mit
das kommt ganz darauf an wo Sie sich
informieren wer sich zum Beispiel die
Mühe macht und Telegramm Kanäle liest
der findet dort neben jeder Menge
Propaganda auch immer noch unabhängigen
russischen Journalismus und kann sich
ein relativ breites Bild des Geschehens
machen wer allerdings Staatsfernsehen
schaut russisches der bekommt zwar auch
Beiträge gezeigt über die sogenannte
Umgruppierung aber eben mit Fokus auf
den ukrainischen Verlusten allerdings
selbst dort werden in den letzten Tagen
interessante Zwischentöne laut und zwar
zum Beispiel ist es so dass die
talkshow-gäste jetzt ab und zu von Krieg
sprechen dabei soll der hier offiziell
und nach Willen der Machthaber ja nur
spezialoperation heißen und hier und da
da wurde auch schon mal laut darüber
nachgedacht ob man angesichts der
derzeitigen Entwicklungen in der Ukraine
nicht vielleicht nach einer politischen
Lösung suchen sollte das alles das sind
im Moment nur Nuancen aber nach den
letzten Monaten in denen es fast gar
keine kritischen Stimmen hier in
Russland mehr gab da lassen sie eben
doch aufhorchen und jetzt gibt es ein
paar Lokalpolitiker in Moskau und
Petersburg die auch von Krieg sprechen
und Putin kritisiert haben könnte daraus
ein ernstzunehmender Protest auch der
Zivilgesellschaft werden
ja diese 18 stadtabgeordneten die haben
Präsident Putin zum Rücktritt
aufgefordert sie argumentieren unter
anderem damit dass die Rhetorik die
aggressive Rhetorik des Präsidenten das
Land zurück in die Zeiten des Kalten
Krieges geführt habe und auch unter
ultra-nationalistischen Kommentatoren
und Bloggern da macht sich Kritik am
präsidentenpreis zum Beispiel daran dass
er bisher eben noch keine general
Mobilmachung ausgerufen hat und auch
daran dass er am Wochenende lieber ein
Riesenrad eingeweiht hat als sich um die
Ukraine zu kümmern aber all diese
stimmen diese kritischen Stimmen die
sind noch relativ vereinzelt und auch
nicht sonderlich prominent und der
Machtapparat der wird sicherlich alles
daran setzen sie zum Schweigen zu
bringen bevor daraus eben ein breiter
Protest werden könnte vielen Dank für
diese Einschätzung aus Moskau
Russlands Krieg in der Ukraine treibt
die Energiepreise in schwindelnde Höhen
und der Politik Angstschweiß auf die
Stirn denn in Niedersachsen wird in vier
Wochen ein neuer Landtag gewählt
ausgerechnet im selbst ernannten
Energieland Nr 1 natürlich will in
Hannover niemand mehr Schröder
nordstream-land sein die SPD setzt jetzt
lieber auf Windräder und das gerade
entstehende lng-terminal und die Bürger
können nun darüber abstimmen ob sie sich
von der Politik genügend unterstützt
fühlen Elisabeth Schmidt berichtet aus
dem Wahlkampf in Niedersachsen
es sind die spitzenmotive der
niedersächsischen Spitzenkandidaten ein
wasserstoffzug in Bremervörde die
Baustelle des flüssig-erdgasterminals in
Wilhelmshaven Energie der Zukunft
Energiekrise daran kommt bei dieser
Landtagswahl keiner vorbei die FDP
plakatiert seit dieser Woche pro
Atomkraft das niedersächsische AKW
Emsland soll es einzig ist der drei
verbliebenen deutschen Meiler zum
Jahresende komplett vom Netz gehen ein
Fehler sagt der liberale Spitzenkandidat
heute demonstrativer Besuch beim
AKW-Betreiber in Lingen aus meiner Sicht
sind ideologische Gründe und maßgeblich
auch der Landtagswahlkampf dass man
diese Anlage hier nicht einmal in den
streckbetrieb übernehmen will es ist ein
Seitenhieb auf den grünen
Bundeswirtschaftsminister Harbeck wollte
am Nachmittag hier in Lüneburg
eigentlich wahlkampfhilfeleisten sagte
aber kurzfristig ab Krise first so die
Begründung in Umfragen liegt das
niedersächsische grüne Spitzen Duo nach
SPD und CDU zurzeit auf Platz 3 und will
einiges besser machen als die amtierende
groko Robert Habeck fordert 2,2% der
Fläche für die Windenergie Niedersachsen
wir haben nur 1,1 also da muss
Niedersachsen schneller werden auch in
Niedersachsen wurden gerade mal 18
Windräder dieses erste Halbjahr gebaut
viel viel zu wenig diesen Vorwurf muss
sich Amtsinhaber Stefan weil gefallen
lassen
symbolträchtige Auftritt in einer
Backstube der spd-ministerpräsident will
in seiner dritten Amtszeit weiter
anpacken und sichert kleinen und
mittleren Unternehmen wie den Bäcker
besondere Unterstützung zu wir müssen
aufpassen dass aus der Energiekrise
keine soziale Krise wird und dann keine
politische Krise und wir wollen lieber
Schutzschirme jetzt bauen als dann in
einem halben Jahr über Rettungsschirme
zu reden sein Herausforderer und
Wirtschaftsminister Bernd Althusmann CDU
will sich aus der juniorrolle in der
niedersächsischen großen Koalition
befreien und liebäugelt mit Schwarz-Grün
doch das Eis ist dünn teilte er zuletzt
doch gegen die Grünen aus
die Grünen massiv aus Niedersachsen
wollten das Liegen auf keinen Fall
wieder ins Netz geht ich kann das nicht
verstehen es ist das modernste ist das
jüngste Atomkraftwerk so laufen wir in
eine Gas und in eine Stromlücke im
nächsten Jahr und das ist ein Schaden
für die gesamte Wirtschaft die AFD gilt
als zerstritten in Niedersachsen machte
zuletzt Stimmung gegen ukrainische
geflüchtete und geht nun in gemäßigterem
Ton mit ihrer Energiepolitik auf Stimmen
fangen CO2-Steuer aussetzen
Energiesteuern senken keine gasumlage
Nord Stream 2 öffnen Atomkraftwerke
länger laufen lassen am 9 oktober wird
in Niedersachsen gewählt doch es werden
wohl bundespolitische Themen sein die
darüber entscheiden wer das
energiegeladene Rennen für sich
entscheidet
und hier geht es jetzt weiter mit den
Nachrichten und da bleiben wir beim
Thema Energieversorgung Gundula israel
kann mit seinen Gasvorkommen rund zehn
Prozent des Erdgases ersetzen das
Russland bislang an Europa geliefert hat
das sagte Ministerpräsident Lapid nach
dem Treffen mit Bundeskanzler Scholz in
Berlin Lapid erklärte erhoffe das
Gasexporte nach Europa schon nächstes
Jahr möglich sein zum Eklat um die
holocaust-vorwürfe von Palästinenser
Präsident Abbas gegen Israel sagte Lapid
Scholz sei von Abbas überrascht worden
er dankte seinem so wirklich Freund Olaf
Scholz für dessen schnelle und deutliche
Stellungnahme
nach der Entscheidung der Schweiz für
den Bau eines
atommüllentlagers nahe der deutschen
Grenze drängt die Bundesregierung auf
Ausgleichszahlungen für die Betroffenen
deutschen Gemeinden wie Hohentengen dort
wird das geplante atomlager abgelehnt
die Schweizer Behörden verteidigten
dagegen in Bären die Standortwahl die
Region nördlich Lägern biete aus
geologischen Gründen den sichersten Ort
für ein Tiefenlager erste Atomabfälle
sollen dort ab 2050 eingelagert werden
bei der Parlamentswahl in Schweden liegt
nach bislang vorliegenden Ergebnissen
das rechte Lager hauchdünn mit einem
sitzvorsprung vor dem linken Bündnis von
Ministerpräsidentin anderschon nach
Auszählung fast aller Wahlbezirke kommt
der konservativ Rechte Block um
Oppositionsführer Christa schon auf
49,8 Prozent der Stimmen und profitiert
dabei vom Erfolg der rechtsnationalen
Schweden Demokraten mit
20,7% den Wahl gewinnen das vorläufige
Ergebnis wird frühestens am Mittwoch
erwartet
Krebsforscher warnen vor erhöhtem
Alkoholkonsum laut deutscher Krebshilfe
dem Krebsforschungszentrum und der
Krebsgesellschaft erkranken jährlich
20.000 Menschen in Folge von
Alkoholkonsum an bösartigen Tumoren vor
allem im Mund und Rachenraum in
Speiseröhre und Darm mehr als 8000 Krebs
Todesfälle im Jahr sein auf Alkohol
zurückzuführen
die
Trauerzeremonien in Großbritannien sahen
heute Beileidsbekundungen durch die
Parlamente vor in London betonte König
Charles der dritte dabei vor beiden
Kammern die Bedeutung des Parlaments für
die Demokratie anschließend reistet
Charles nach Schottland wo er einen
Trauerzug zu Ehren seiner verstorbenen
Mutter begleitete danach nahm er auch
die Beileidsbekundung des schottischen
Parlaments entgegen und sprach mit
Regierungschefin sturchon morgen wird
Charles in Nordirland erwartet und der
Sarg der Queen nach London übergeführt
am Abend haben in Edinburgh ihre vier
Kinder die Totenwache gehalten
noch nie haben so viele Menschen in
Deutschland Schutz gesucht wie im Moment
fast drei Millionen geflüchtete sind in
Deutschland registriert mehr als in der
migrationskrise von 2015 der Grund ist
natürlich der ukraine-krieg der rund
eine Million Menschen hauptsächlich
Frauen und Kinder zu uns brachte was
freundliche und unbürokratisch begann
wird angesichts dieser Zahlen langsam
schwierig 12 von 16 Bundesländern haben
inzwischen einen Aufnahmestopp verhängt
weil sie nicht mehr wissen wie sie die
Menschen unterbringen sollen schon
werden wieder Turnhallen geräumt Jutta
sonnewald berichtet aus dem bayerischen
deggendorf
seit der Krieg in ihrer ehemaligen
Heimat ausgebrochen ist engagiert sich
Victoria Schüssler für Flüchtlinge aus
der Ukraine rund 300 von ihnen hat sie
eine Notunterkunft bieten können im
Vereinsheim des baseball-clubs der
Deggendorf Dragons für viele wie Olga
und war dem Findus mit ihren zwei
kleinen Söhnen hat sie inzwischen eine
Wohnung gefunden die Hürden sind große
und auch die Bürokratie die ist manchmal
sehr stark unflexibel immer wieder ist
man am Ende der Kräfte etwa eine Million
Menschen sind seit Ausbruch des Krieges
vor etwas über einem halben Jahr nach
Deutschland geflohen alleine Bayern hat
rund 175.000 aufgenommen immer mehr
Länder und Kommunen verhängen einen
Aufnahmestopp manche erwegen gar
Sporthallen wieder als Notunterkünfte zu
aktivieren die Wohnungssituation war ja
vorher schon angespannt und jetzt kommen
neue Leute kommen mehr Leute noch nach
Deggendorf in den Landkreis das glaube
ich sind die Grenzen die uns langsam
erreichen Bayerns innen derzeit
gleichzeitig Vorsitzende der
Innenministerkonferenz weiß wie die
Städte und Kommunen echzen auch in
anderen Bundesländern allein im
Freistaat hat sich die Zahl der
geflüchteten im vergangenen Jahr mehr
als verfünffacht es geht ja nicht nur um
die ukrainischen Flüchtlinge sondern es
sind die Zahlen von Asylbewerbern aus
anderen Teilen der Welt jetzt wieder
deutlich angestiegen es muss sich die
Bundesregierung darum kümmern und nicht
so tun als ob sie noch beliebig viele
zusätzliche weitere Flüchtlinge
aufnehmen könnte zumindest eines klappt
momentan schnell und unbürokratisch mehr
als 100.000 ukrainische Flüchtlinge
haben bisher bundesweit an einem Sprach-
und Integrationskurs wie diesem in
München teilgenommen das BAMF hat in den
vergangenen fünf Monaten die Zahl der
Plätze verdoppelt hier unterrichtet
Julia Menke aus Russland doch ihre
herkunftsspiele keine Rolle sagt sie im
Gegenteil dass sie sich problemlos
verständigen können verbindet gerade
wenn die Kriegstraumata die geflüchteten
wieder einholen
dann tröste ich auch die Teilnehmer dann
weinen wir auch zu sagen wir hatten
schon solche Momente dass eine
Teilnehmerin ihren Mann verloren hat und
ist dann gekommen und war einfach in
Tränen aufgelöst und hat nur geweint und
wie kam einfach alle dazu haben sie
umarmt
gedrückt und das hilft ja natürlich auch
ziel des Kurses das auch fast alle
erreichen ist das Sprachniveau B1 Ziel
der meisten Teilnehmerinnen und
Teilnehmer ist es hier möglichst bald
einen Job zu finden
ich habe eine Ausbildung als
systemanalytikerin gemacht ich hoffe
dass ich auch hier in der IT-Branche
arbeiten kann
Victoria Schüssler bleibt ihren
geflüchteten Landsleuten ihren
Schützlingen weiterhin verbunden hilft
und unterstützt wo sie nur kann mit
ihrer Familie versucht sie ihnen ein
Stück Normalität zu bieten schließlich
so sagt sie wissen die meisten nicht ob
und wann sie je in ihre Heimat
zurückkehren können
und hier geht es weiter mit Gundula und
Nachrichten aus der Wirtschaft drastisch
hat das Münchner ifo Institut seine
Konjunkturprognose für dieses und
nächstes Jahr gekappt Deutschland werde
in eine winterrezession Abrutschen sagen
die Forscher und warnen davor Valerie
Halle damit war zwar zu rechnen aber die
neuen ifozahlen erschrecken schon ja
weil wir vermutlich mit schwierigen
Monaten rechnen müssen die Zeichen
stehen auf Rezession wegen der
gestiegenen Energiepreise Anfang
nächsten Jahres dürften die Strom- und
Gaspreise auch noch mal deutlich steigen
denn dann werden viele Energieversorger
ihre höheren Beschaffungskosten an die
Kunden weiterreichen düstere Prognose
für dieses Jahr rechnet das Ifo-Institut
statt mit einem Wachstum von 2,5 nur
noch mit 1,6 Prozent kommendes Jahr soll
die Konjunktur statt um 3,3% zu wachsen
sogar schrumpfen um 0,3 Prozent und die
rekordinflation wird sich laut Telefon
noch verschärfen dieses Jahr 8,1 Prozent
2023 dann
9,3%. Entspannung sieht das Ifo-Institut
auch aber erst übernächstes Jahr dann
sollte auch die Inflation wieder
zurückgegangen sein immerhin schwere
Auswirkungen am Arbeitsmarkt werden
nicht erwartet erwähnenswert weil
überraschend ein Blick auf den äußerst
robusten DAX heute über 300 Punkte im
Plus knapp 800 Punkte ist der Dax seit
vergangenem Montag gestiegen dafür gibt
es mögliche viele oder verschiedene
mögliche Erklärungen eine davon die
Hoffnung auf eine Wende im Ukraine Krieg
bis aber die Rede sein kann von einer
echten Erholung am Aktienmarkt dürfte es
noch ein langer Weg sein ja vielen Dank
valerina Frankfurt es sind Faktoren die
eben belasten auch die
Tarifverhandlungen der Metall- und
Elektroindustrie mit bundesweit knapp
vier Millionen Beschäftigten nach dem
Auftakt in Hannover wurden die
Verhandlungen auf oktober vertagt das
angesichts der hohen Inflation von der
Gewerkschaft geforderte Lohnplus von
8%, sei so Niedersachsens
metallarbeitgeber-chef Schmidt aus der
Zeit gefallen die IG Metall droht
bereits mit Warnstreiks
Lufthansa-Kunden dagegen müssen bis
nächsten Sommer keine weiteren Streiks
der Piloten befürchten Konzern und
Gewerkschaft vereinbarten eine
Übergangslösung mit einer
Friedenspflicht bis Ende Juni 23 bis
dahin soll vertraulich noch strittiges
geklärt werden beschlossen ist bereits
eine Lohnerhöhung für die Piloten in
zwei Schritten um insgesamt 980 Euro pro
Monat und noch eine tennis-sensation
Teenager Carlos al Caras hat bei den US
Open in New York seinen ersten Grand
slam-titel gewonnen und Geschichte
geschrieben im Finale setzte sich der 19
Jahre alte Spanier gegen den auch erst
23-jährige Norweger Kasper Rüth in vier
Sätzen durch dazu kann sich alcaras
neben Siegerpokal und Millionen
Preisgeld auch über Platz eins der
Weltrangliste freuen als jüngster
Spieler überhaupt
neun Mal reiste der dänische Filmemacher
Lars ostenfeld in die Gletscherwelt von
Grönland für einen Film über Forscher
die ihr eigenes Leben riskieren um das
was uns alle bedroht zu verstehen den
Klimawandel
und weil der Regisseur ganz nah dran
sein wollte musste er zuerst selbst
lernen sich im Eis zu bewegen und sich
in steile Trichter abzuseilen
herausgekommen ist ein bildgewaltiger
Film mit einer Botschaft die uns nicht
mehr überraschen kann das Eis schmilzt
noch schneller als gedacht um die Wucht
zu verstärken holte ostenfeld sich für
die deutsche Version die Stimme eines
Rockstars Nadja nasser berichtet
Grönland der Inland Eisfeld im Sommer
hier verbirgt sich ein Geheimnis über
unsere Zukunft auf den ersten Blick sind
es beeindruckend schöne Bilder aus dem
eis-grönland die der dänische Filme
Macher Lars ostenfeld mit seiner Kamera
eingefangen hat was sie tatsächlich
zeigen sind erschreckende Folgen des
Klimawandels das Eis schmilzt der
Meeresspiegel steigt das wissen wir
alles aber wie schnell das passiert weiß
niemand
obwohl das vielleicht die drängendste
Frage ist auf die wir eine Antwort
finden müssen
was wir wissen stammt von
Satellitenaufnahmen Modellen Überflügen
nur wenige Forscher trauen sich
tatsächlich auf und in das Eis hinein
denn das könnte ihr Leben kosten diese
Arbeit ist sehr gefährlich
drei von ihnen begleitete er
gletscherforscher Alan Hubert will
wissen wie viel Schmelzwasser auch im
Winter noch im Eis übrig bleibt und
steigt in ein 180 Meter tiefes Loch
hinab um im Inneren des Eises zu bohren
ein riskantes Unterfangen ich halte mein
Leben nicht für so wichtig dass ich das
Risiko nicht eingehen würde und
kräftezehrend echt harte Arbeit hier
runterzukommen weiß Gott wie wir wieder
rauskommen sollte der Boden im Winter
nicht mehr durchgefroren sein ein
katastrophales Zeichen und tatsächlich
die Eisdecke ist nur noch dünn unsere
Vorhersagen über den Anstieg des
Meeresspiegels könnten ganz schön
daneben liegen ich mache mir große
Sorgen über die Zukunft heißen alle der
Klimawandel passiert aber tun wir
wirklich genug dafür uns alle zu retten
ich hoffe dass die Leute das so ernst
nehmen wie es ist wir müssen endlich auf
diese Forscher hören
eine aufrüttelnde Dokumentation mit
prominenter Unterstützung Tote Hosen
Sänger Campino war von dem Film so
beeindruckt dass er ihm seine Stimme
lief wir haben keine Ahnung wie hoch wir
die Dämme in Zukunft bauen müssen oder
wie die Ufer aussehen sollten wo werden
Menschen leben können das ist so eine
richtige Ohrfeige slappende face hinein
so schön sagt davon brauchen wir immer
wieder welche in allen möglichen
Richtungen denn der Mensch ist einfach
so konzipiert dass er sich dass er gute
Verdrängungsmechanismen hat wenn die
becommerware wenn man erkennt was hier
vor sich geht beim Klimawandel
dann schläft man nachts nicht mehr ruhig
würdet nein into the eyes ist eine
erschreckende Bestandsaufnahme ein
Appell endlich auf das zu hören was das
Eis uns über unsere Zukunft erzählen
kann
und das war es von uns hier geht es
jetzt weiter mit dem montagskino und dem
action thriller ein fauler deal
und direkt danach um 23 Uhr meldet sich
Hanna Zimmermann mit unserem heute
journal Update und einem Interview mit
nuripur von den Grünen in einen guten
Abend und bis morgen tschüss
[Musik]
schönen guten Abend und herzlich
willkommen zum Wetter schauen wir zurück
auf den vergangenen Monat auf den August
europaweit und es war deutlich zu warm
im Osten über der Mitte oder auch nach
Westen hin einzig vor der iberischen
Halbinsel da war es zu kühl
Temperaturabweichung ist so groß es ist
der wärmste August geworden der letzte
Monat der diesen Titel trug war 2018 ja
und das war auch zu trocken aber die
Trockenheit hat allmählich ein Ende denn
der ehemalige Hurrikan Daniel dreht sich
vor der iberischen Halbinsel und pumpt
feuchte und warme Luft von Süden heran
von Norden erreichte uns kühle und es
bildet sich eine Luftmassengrenze quer
über Deutschlands über Deutschland und
in den nächsten Tagen gibt es viel Regen
schau mal die nachts von Norden her
schwenkt Regen durch nach Osten
ansonsten wird es trocken sein bei
Temperaturen von 8 im Südosten
Deutschlands und 16 Grad Richtung
Nordsee morgen dann wird der Regen im
Osten allmählich nachlassen ansonsten
bildet sich aber über der Mitte diese
Luftmassengrenze mit Regen aus und vor
allem am späten Nachmittag und in der
darauffolgenden Nacht gibt es kräftigen
Regen teils bis 30 50 Liter auf dem
Quadratmeter und bei Gewittern noch mehr
ja und die Temperaturen dazu 29 Grad im
Südwesten und 18 Grad im Norden ja und
der Mittwoch eben ein sehr regnerischer
Tag im Süden kräftige Gewitter bei 16
bis 27 Grad und auch danach gibt es
einige Schauer ein schönen Abend